let's learn about matrices so what is a
and what if what I mean when I say
matrices well matrices is just the
plural for matrix which is probably a
word you're familiar with more because
of Hollywood than because of mathematics
so what is a matrix well it's actually a
pretty simple idea it's it's just a
table of numbers that's all a matrix is
so let me let me draw a matrix for you I
don't like that toothpaste colored blue
so let me use another color so this is
an example of a matrix if I said I don't
know I'm gonna pick some random random
numbers out 5 1 2 3 0 minus 5 that is a
matrix and all it is is a table of
numbers and often times you know if you
wanted to have a variable for matrix you
use a capital letter so you know we can
use a capital A and sometimes in some
books they make an extra bold so it's
like a bold a would be a matrix and just
a little bit of notation so they would
call this matrix or we would call this
matrix just by convention you would call
this a 2 by 3 matrix and sometimes they
actually write it 2x3 below the bold
letter they used to represent the matrix
and what is 2 and what is 3 well 2 is
the number of rows right we have 1 row
to row all right this is a row this is a
row and we have 3 columns 1 2 3 so
that's why it's called a 2x3 matrix so
when you say you know if I said a if I
said that B I'll do it extra bold if B
is a 5 by 2 matrix that means that B
would have I could let me do one I'll
just type in number 0 minus 5 10 and it
has 2 so it has five rows has two
columns so I'll have another column here
so let's say minus 10 3 I'm just putting
in random numbers here 7 2 pi that is a
5 by 2 matrix so I think you'd I have
kind of a convention that all the matrix
is is the table of numbers you can
represent it when you're doing it in
variable
form you represented as a bold-faced
capital letters sometimes you'd write a
2x3 there and you can actually reference
the terms of the matrix so I think in
this example in the top example where we
have matrix a if someone wanted a
reference let's say this this element of
the matrix so what is that that is in
the second row it's in Row 2 and it's in
column 2 right this is column 1 this is
column 2 is Row 1 Row 2 so it's in the
second row second column so sometimes
people will write that a and they'll
write you know 2 comma 2 is equal to 0
or they might write sometimes they'll
write a lowercase a 2 comma 2 is equal
to 0 and you know just just as well what
is a now these are just the same thing
I'm just doing this to expose you to the
notation because a lot of this really is
just notation so what is a 1 comma 3
well that means we're in the first row
and the third column first row 1 2 3
it's this value right here so that
equals 2 so this is just all of them
tation of what a matrix is this is a
table of numbers it can be represented
this way we can represent its different
elements that way so you might be asking
Sal well that's nice a table of numbers
with fancy words and fancy notations but
what is it good for and that's the
interesting point a matrix is just a
data representation it's just a way of
writing down data I mean that's all it
is it says it's a table of numbers but
it can be used to represent a whole set
of phenomenon and if you're doing this
in in your algebra 1 or your algebra 2
class you're probably using it to
represent linear equations but we'll
learn later that it and and I'll do a
whole set of videos on applying matrices
to a whole bunch of different things but
it can represent it's very powerful in
and if you are if you're doing computer
graphics a matrix is the elements can
represent pixels on your screen they can
represent points in coordinate space
they could represent who knows that
there's tons of things that they can
represent but the important thing there
to realize is the matrix is
it's not a natural phenomenon it's not
like a it's not like a lot of the
mathematical concepts we've been looking
at it's a way to represent a
mathematical concept or way of
representing values but you kind of have
to define what it's representing but
let's put that on the backburner a
little bit in terms of what it actually
represents and then all my wife is here
she's looking for our filing cabinet
weights way back to what I was doing so
so let's let's put on the back burner
what a matrix is actually representing
and let's learn the convention because I
think at least initially that tends to
be the hardest part how do you add
matrices how do you multiply matrices
how do you invert a matrix YZ how do you
find that determinant of a matrix I know
all of those words might sound
unfamiliar unless you've already been
confused by them in your in your algebra
class so I'm going to teach you all of
those things first which are all just
really human defined conventions and
then later on I'll make a whole bunch of
videos on the intuition behind them and
what they actually represent so let's
get started so let's say I wanted to add
these two matrices let's say the first
one and let me switch colors let's say
I'll do relatively small ones just not
waste space say have the matrix 3
negative 1 so I don't know to 0 I don't
know let's call that a capital A and
let's say matrix B and I'm just making
up numbers matrix B is equal to minus 7
2 3 5 so my question to you is what is a
so I'm doing it bold like they do in the
textbooks plus matrix B so I'm adding
two matrices and once again this is just
human convention someone defined how
matrices add they could have defined it
some other way but they said we're gonna
make matrices add the way I'm about to
show you because it's useful for a whole
set of phenomenon so when you add two
matrices you essentially just add the
corresponding elements so how does that
work well you add the element that's in
row
one column one to the elements Row one
column one right so it's three plus
minus seven there's a three plus minus
seven that'll be the one one element
then the Row one column two element will
be minus one plus two minus one plus two
put parentheses around them so you know
that these are separate elements and you
could guess how this just keeps going
and then this this element will be 2
plus 3 so 2 plus 3 and this element this
last element will be zero plus five zero
plus five so that equals 1 3 plus minus
seven that is minus four minus 1 plus 2
that's 1 2 plus 3 is 5 and 0 plus 5 is 5
so there we have it that is how we
humans have defined the addition of two
matrices and by this definition you can
imagine that this is going to be the
same thing as B plus a right remember
this is something we have to think about
because we're not we're not adding
numbers anymore you know that you know 1
plus 2 is the same thing as 2 plus 1 or
you know any two normal numbers doesn't
matter what order you you add them it
but matrices it's not completely obvious
but when you define it in this way it
doesn't matter if we do a plus B or B
plus a right if we did we plus a this
would just say negative 7 plus 3 this
would say 2 plus negative 1 but it all
it would come out to the same values
that is matrix addition and you can
imagine matrix subtraction it's
essentially the same thing we would well
actually let me let me show you what
would be a minus B a minus B a minus B
well you could also view this is capital
B with some matrix that's why I'm making
extra bold well that's the same thing as
a plus minus 1 times B and what's B well
B is minus 7 2 3 5 and when you multiply
a scalar when you just multiply a number
times a matrix you just multiply that
number times every one of its elements
so that equals a matrix a
plus the matrix we just multiply this
negative one times every element in here
so 7 minus 2 minus 3 and 5 and then we
could do what's do what we did up there
and we know what a is so this would
equal let's see a is up here so 3 plus 7
is 10 negative 1 plus negative 2 is
minus 3/2 plus minus 3 is minus 1 and 0
plus 5 is 5 and you didn't have to go
through this exercise right here you
could have literally just subtracted
these elements from these elements and
you would have gotten the same value I
did this because I wanted to show you
also that multiplying a scalar times or
you know just a value or a number times
a matrix is just multiplying though that
number times all of the elements of the
matrix and so what by this definition of
matrix addition what do we know well we
know that both matrices have to be the
same size by this definition the way
we're adding so for example you could
add these two matrices
you could add I don't know 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 to this matrix - I don't know - 10
minus 100 minus 1,000 I'm making up
numbers 1 0 0 1 0 1 you can add these
two matrices right because they have the
same number of rows the same number of
columns so for example the when you if
you were to add them the first term up
here would be 1 plus minus 10 so it
would be minus 9 2 plus 4 minus 100
minus 98 I think you get the point you
know you would have exactly nine
elements and you would have three rows
and three columns but you could not add
these two matrices you could not add let
me do it in a different color just so
it's different
you could not add this blue you could
not add this matrix - 3 - to the matrix
to the matrix
I don't know 9 7 and why can you not add
them well they don't have corresponding
elements to add up this is a this is a
one row by two column this is 1 by 2 and
this is 2 by 1 so they don't have the
two same dimensions so we can't add or
subtract to these matrices and this is a
side note when a matrix has when one of
its dimensions is 1 so for example here
you have one row and multiple columns
this is actually called a row vector a
vector is essentially a one dimensional
matrix where one of the dimensions is 1
so this is a row vector and similarly
this is a column vector and that's just
a little extra terminology you should
know if you take linear algebra and
calculus your professor might use those
terms and it's good to be familiar with
it but anyway I'm pushing 11 minutes so
I will continue this in the next video
see you soon